newfoundland here is only a recent
addition to canada
having joined it in 1949. yet canada was
confederated in 1867 and so the two
remain divided for nearly a century
which raises a pretty obvious question
why why did it take so long for
newfoundland to join canada
so when the colonies which would become
canada were debating confederation in
1864
politicians in newfoundland began to
discuss the issue at home did they want
to be a part of this new canada and take
their rightful place in the world or
just sit on the sidelines and watch
history pass them by
turns out the sidelines were just fine
and newfoundland would sit this canada
thing out
their primary reasons were that one
whilst the politicians there were
largely pro-confederation the people
were most certainly not
which brings us on to reason number two
catholics
specifically french catholics who made a
precisely chunk of this new canada's
population and thus had a lot of
influence
and the people of newfoundland proud
protestants that they were were having
none of that
and the third reason was economic
newfoundland had low taxes and there
were concerns that a new central
government in ottawa would raise them to
pay for things like railways and a
national military
so what changed well newfoundland
continued to develop on its own and its
people for the most part still wish to
remain independent there was a very
sudden change of heart in 1895 when the
newfoundland premier william whiteway
made a plea to join the confederation
and this was totally because they loved
canada and nothing to do with the
massive financial crisis that had just
hit them
the canadians said no and so they were
left to struggle on with mountains of
debt
after this the people of newfoundland
were still against confederation and in
1907 newfoundland was promoted from a
colony to a dominion
meaning that its continued independence
seemed assured and its history largely
mirrored those of the other dominions
throughout the early 20th century there
were reforms at home political scandals
world war 1 greater exploitation of
natural resources and a general
improvement in the economic situation
that was at least until the great
depression which could only mean one
thing
pain newfoundland was essentially
bankrupted by this and so it went for
the previous tactic of trying to sell
itself to canada
the canadians said no because it sounded
expensive and the british refused to
help unless newfoundland suspended its
government and let them run it instead
which they did in 1934 and the british
took over before proceeding to also be
terrible at running the place
so in world war ii the british
negotiated away basing rights to the
united states in return for some much
needed ships and the americans began
massive investment in the area
this drastically improved the living
standards of the people living there and
after the war many people demanded that
british rule come to an end which meant
it was time for a referendum
the people had two choices go back to
being independent or remain
under british control the first option
terrified the british because it would
have meant newfoundland increasing its
ties with the united states and there
were some there even advocating for
statehood
this option also terrified the canadians
because with these borders canada's
access to the atlantic could be
restricted
and along with it britain's access to
canadian resources
and so to stop this potential outcome
from happening the british and canadians
teamed up to add a third option to the
ballot
join canada now the representatives of
newfoundland didn't want this option but
that's not how british rule worked and
so
on the ballot it went the referendum was
held in 1948 and whichever option gained
50
of the vote that would be the action
taken but none of them won and so a
second referendum this time without the
potential to continue british rule was
held and union with canada won with 52
percent of the vote
and after some negotiations newfoundland
ceased to exist as a nation and became a
part of canada the next year
i hope you enjoyed this episode and
thank you for watching with a special
thanks to my patrons
james bisonette kelly money maker alex
schwinn mr wolfe captain cydog adam
stalter
skye chappelle marvin casou aaron the
white mo
james castaneda jordan longley jerry
landon gustav swan rasheed ali winston k
wood boogerly wiggily spinning three
plates coppertone maggie paskowski
spencer lightfoot matthew shipley robert
wetzel corso wolff the mc whopper
anthony beckett marcus asner lil brep
and tc and charles the first